wir haben einen impfstoff der einen
eigenschutz ist ist es nicht ein
impfstoff der uns eine herren immunität
bringen wird ist jeder der sich schützen
will kann sich schützen geimpft zu
werden das ist vor allem in dem man sich
impfen lässt das ist vor allem wichtig
für eltern und lehrer
denn natürlich werden wir infektionen in
schulen sehen
wir dürfen aber in keinen druck aufbauen
und da das sehe ich als ganz wichtigen
punkt wir dürfen keinen druck aufbauen
bei kindern und jugendlichen ab zwölf
jahren dass sie sich jetzt impfen lassen
müssen damit sie zum beispiel am
unterricht teilnehmen können ich habe
gestern von einem schüler gehört dass
das mobbing entsteht weil er noch kann
mit 13 jahren noch keinen impfpass hat
also das nicht vorzeigen kann das finde
ich eine ganz schwierige konsequenz aus
dem nicht eine ganz schwierige
entwicklung wenn man sich überlegt
kinder und jugendliche haben keine
schweren verläufe und daher darf da auch
kein druck entstehen wenn jemand sich
selber entscheiden möchte sich impfen
lassen dann soll er das machen aber und
ich finde es auch gut wenn das macht
aber es darf kein druck in der
gesellschaft aufbauen aufgebaut werden
und auch nicht darüber eine entscheidung
auch präsenzunterricht jetzt vom
impfstatus zum beispiel der kinder
abhängt hendrix strikt sagt es darf
dieses klima nicht aufgebaut werden aber
fakt ist ja es ist längst aufgebaut
worden ja das ist tatsächlich ein
mobbing klima gegen kinder und man muss
es einmal so klar sagen hier hat eine in
der entscheidung spitze weitgehend
kinderlose regierung ein klima
geschaffen in dem kinder inzwischen
angst in täglicher angst leben angst
davor dass sie ihre eltern gefährden
könnten angst davor dass sie ihre lehrer
ansteckt angst davor ob sie jemals
wieder normal leben werden dass kinder
auf einmal das gefühl haben sie sind
dafür verantwortlich die gesellschaft zu
schützen was hier passiert ist ist in
der historische umkehr unseres
menschenbildes erwachsene schützen
kinder und nicht kinder schützen
erwachsene und schon gar nicht müssen
kinder erwachsene schützen aufgrund von
inzwischen hoch ideologisierten ideen
dass man die kinder quasi jetzt über
anderthalb jahre als pandemie und
virenschleuder
verunglimpft hat was mit der realität
rein gar nichts zu tun hat und zu tun
hat und das in einer zeit in der
erwachsenen vollkommen problemlos die
entscheidung treffen können sich selber
zu schützen und kinder nach allem was
wir wissen hat eben gesagt so gut wie
nicht von schweren verläufen von diesem
von diesem virus betroffen sind es gibt
überhaupt keinen grund für das was
gerade passiert passiert und dass kinder
jetzt immer noch in der angst leben dass
die schulen wieder schließen und sie
wieder ihre freunde ich sehen das ist im
negativen sinne eine historische
leistung dieser regierung
[Musik]